♪ ♪ ♪
Une longue complainte sur
la place Ste Sophie:
"Comment est-ce possible de ne
pas t'aimer, Kiev," dit la
chanson. Une musique nostalgique
qui semble exprimer aussi la
lassitude d'un pays en guerre.
Ici, les Ukrainiens qui
contemplent chaque jour les
épaves d'équipements russes
calcinés trophée
de guerre, espèrent deux choses.
Max et sa petite famille
espèrent que son président
réussira à convaincre les
partenaires étrangers de fournir
davantage d'armes à son pays.
Quant à Irina et Vassil, c'est
l'envie plus que tout de faire
partie de la grande famille
européenne.
À quelques coins de rues
de ces souhaits, de grandes
pointures pour peut-être
les exaucer. Emmanuel Macron,
Mario Draghi et Olaf Scholz,
une première en sol ukrainien.
Les discussions sont sérieuses,
les demandes ukrainiennes
entendues.
L'Europe est à vos côtés,
réaffirme le président français.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France- Elle lel
le faudra, jusqu'à la victoire,
qui aura le visage du retour
de la paix dans une Ukraine
libre et indépendante.
- L'Allemagne elle, promet
d'autres livraisons d'armes.
Et puis surtout, L'Italie
annonce le soutien commun des
trois partenaires pour soutenir
le traitement immédiat de la
ure de l'Ukraine au sein
de l'Union européenne.
Le président ukrainien fera tout
ce qu'il peut pour que ce rêve
devenu besoin essentiel devienne
réalité.
Oubliez donc les frictions entrt
Zelensky, à cause de commentaire
récent du président français
sur la nécessité de ne pas
humilier la Russie et Vladimir
Poutine. La relation seraitau b.
Dans les ruines de la ville
d'Irpin aux portes de Kiev,
la France salue le courage de ce
peuple face à l'invasion russe.
- Il faut se représenter
ïsme de l'armée, mais
aussi de la population
ukrainienne.
- Le besoin urgent d'armements
étrangers pour l'Ukraine
continue d'être comblé petit
à petit par les pays européens,
mais pas assez rapidement,
estime Kiev. Quant à la demande
d'adhésion à l'Union européenne,
il faudra attendre une unanimité
parmis les 27 pays membres de
l'Union pour que le dossier de
candidature soit é
Une procédure qui si accélérée
soit-elle, pourrait prendre
des mois voire des années.
Là encore, Volodymyr Zelensky
devra s'armer, de patience.
Ici Fré
Radio-Canada, à Kiev
en Ukraine.